we're seeing how much Jake Paul improved  from his last fight with Woodley to this  fight which is in the the amount of  improvement that Jake Paul's made from  his last fight to this fight really  every fight is insane and it just shows  and it's kudos to Jake Paul for how hard  he works in Camp because to make those  leaps the only way to make those  improvements clearly you're not doing it  in real time in the ring because you  can't fight that frequently so it's  through your training camp and your  coaches so I mean kudos to his coaches  his training Partners the training camp  and for Jake Paul for literally putting  every cell in his body and becoming a  legit boxer because the Jake Paul that  fought Woodley that last one would not  have beat the Sanderson Silva but this  is how fast this kid's getting this is  how good he's getting at boxing because  he's putting in the work he's putting  the time he's taking it serious